Hello world,
it's Saroj and let's talk
about how gradient descent
has evolved over the years.
Tensorflow gives us quite a few
options for picking a gradient,
descent based optimization strategy.
This is what causes our neural
network to actually learn from data,
but it's not immediately
clear how we should pick one.
Once we understand the underlying
details of the most popular ones,
it will become much more
clear which one we should use.
When you study machine
learning for a while,
you start making connections between
these mathematical techniques and the way
we learn.
At this point,
I view pretty much everything through
the lens of data and computation and it's
a beautiful feeling.
For example,
sometimes if our Dataset is
too homogenous after training,
our model will be to fit to this data.
It'll be overfit,
meaning it won't be
able to generalize well,
so if given some different data points,
it will be able to make
an accurate prediction.
We have to keep our training
data diverse and in the same way,
if we keep our brains training data
diverse by traveling and seeking out novel
experiences,
we'll be able to generalize better
and generalization is the hallmark of
intelligence,
so that's why I like anchovies.
If you were to ask what the most
important machine learning technique is,
the answer is without a
doubt gradient descent.
It is the foundation of how we train
intelligent systems and it's based off a
very simple idea.
Time travel instead of immediately
guessing the best solution to a given
objective.
We guess an initial solution
and iteratively step in
a direction closer to a
better solution.
The algorithm just repeats that process
until it arrives at a solution that's
good enough. Since there is no way we can
know the best solution from the start,
this educated guess and check
method is supremely useful.
Gradient descent, find the ideal
minimum, control our variance,
update our parameters and
lead us to convergence.
A simple direct example of
gradient descent would be
if we want it to calculate
the minimum value of x squared. That is
where the wide value is. The smallest.
We could just randomly guess x
values from all over the place,
but if we used gradient descent, we
arrive at a solution way more efficiently.
The derivative of x squared is two x
and we used that derivative to calculate
the gradient at a given point,
so we could first guess three and take
a baby step in the direction opposite of
the gradient and x equals three which is
negative six then the next guest might
be at 2.3 then 1.4 then 0.7
until we finally reached zero,
which is the local minimum.
Both we and the machine can see that
this is the optimal solution since we can
follow the trail of optimization visually
and mathematically as it leads us to
convergence.
Another way of thinking about the idea
of gray and dissent is examining how a
professional athlete improves that a gate.
As long as there is some
objective function that can
measured like the number of
wins in a season and some data that
contributes or detracts from that function
say passes, number of
three pointers, steroids,
that player can iteratively take baby
steps in his routines after analyzing the
data to improve,
so to decide which of the gradient descent
optimization techniques we should use
in our model.
Let's learn about the various discoveries
around grading the sense over the
years.
Traditional gradient descent computes
the gradients of the loss function with
regards to the perimeters for the entire
training datasets for a given number of
epochs.
Since we need to calculate the gradient
of the whole Dataset for just a single
update,
this has relatively slow and even in
tractable for data sets that don't fit in
memory.
So to get around this intractability
we can use to castic gradient descent.
This is where we perform a
parameter update for each
training example and label.
So we just add a loop over our training
data points and calculate the gradient
with regard to each and every one.
These more frequent updates with high
variance because the objective function to
fluctuate more intensely.
This is a good thing in that it helps
it jump to new and possibly better local
minimum.
Whereas standard grading dissent,
we'll only converge to the minimum of
the basin that the parameters are placed
in, but it also complicates convergence
to the exact minimum since it could keep
overshooting.
So an improvement would be to use
minibatch gradient descent as it takes the
best of both worlds. By performing an
update for every subset of training.
Examples that we can decide the size of
training in many batches is usually the
method of choice for training neural
networks. And we usually use the terms,
the Cassick rating dissent.
Even when many batches are used,
the oscillations in plain old SGD make
it hard to reach convergence though.
So a technique called momentum was
invented that lets it navigate along the
relevant directions and softens the
oscillations in the irrelevant directions.
All it does is it adds a fraction of
the direction or update vector of the
previous step to the current step,
which amplifies the speed
and the correct direction.
So it's just like momentum from
classical physics. Thanks Aristotle.
When a ball is pushed down a hill,
it accumulates momentum,
meaning it gets faster and faster.
In the same way,
our momentum term
increases four dimensions,
who's creating Ann's point in the
same direction and reduces updates for
dimensions?
Who's gradients changed direction?
This means faster convergence
and reduced oscillations,
but a researcher named Yuri Nesteroff
saw a problem with momentum.
Once we get close to our goal point,
the momentum is usually pretty high and
it doesn't know that it should slow down,
which could cause it to
miss the minimum entirely.
He solved this problem in a paper he
released in 1983 and we now call this
strategy the nests rob accelerated
gradient in the momentum method.
We compute the gradient,
then make a jump in that direction
amplified by the previous momentum.
In this method we do the same
thing but in a different order.
We first make a jump based on our
previous momentum, calculate the gradient,
then make a correction
which results in an update.
This more anticipatory update prevents
us from going too fast and were more
responsive to changes.
So this idea of more dynamic learning
of adapting our updates to the slope of
our air function is a good one.
Perhaps we could apply it to
our learning rate as well.
Good ideas are good.
That's what Adec Grad does.
It stands for adaptive gradient and
allows the learning rate to adapt based on
the parameters.
So it makes big updates for infrequent
parameters and small updates.
For frequent ones.
It uses a different learning rate for
every parameter at a given time step based
on the past gradients that were
computed for that parameter.
This means that we don't have to
manually tune the learning rate.
It's main weakness though,
is that the learning rate
is always decreasing since
the accumulation of squared
gradients and the denominator
grows because each added
term is always positive.
At some point the learning rate could
get so small that the model is just stops
learning entirely at a delta was
invented to solve this and add a grad.
We're constantly adding a square root
to the some causing the learning rate to
decrease. So instead of summing
all the past square roots,
we restrict the window of accumulated
pass gradients to a fixed size.
We defined the sum of great as a decaying
average of all past squared gradients
instead of just stored
previous squared grades.
So the running average at a time step
depends only on the previous average and
the current gradient.
So now we're getting somewhere,
we're calculating individual
learning rates for each parameter,
calculating momentum values, and we're
preventing a vanishing learning rate.
What could we possibly do to improve here?
Sprinkle in some adaptive momentum.
Since we're calculating learning
rates for each parameter,
why not also store momentum changes
for each of them separately?
That's what Adam does.
It stands for adaptive moment estimation.
We calculate the first moment,
the mean and the second moment the
uncentered variants of the gradients
respectively.
Then we use those values to update the
parameters just like in at a delta.
If we were to visualize these optimization
algorithms during the learning
process, we'll see that
the adaptive learning rate
methods quickly find the right
direction and converge super fast while
momentum and the nest rob accelerated
gray and go in the wrong direction.
So which optimizers should you
use and your neural network?
It seems that Adam is the best overall
choice since it usually outperforms the
rest followed very closely by the other
adaptive learning rate methods out of
Grad and add a delta momentum.
Plain STD and nesteroff strategy are cool,
but when data is sparse,
which it usually is in real world
data sets, they don't perform well.
I know we've talked about a
lot of different optimization
strategies and it's a
lot to take in all at once.
So what better way to apply this knowledge
then by implementing one by yourself?
The coding challenge for this week is to
implement Adam from scratch in python.
Details are in the read me get hub leads,
go into comments and winners will be
announced in one week. If you subscribe,
all of your dreams will come true.
Check out this related video and for now
I'm going to go, so thanks for lunch.